okay so this is the question you're
asking yeah right
in case you're wondering if you ever
struggle with questions where you get
given a function all right so this is my
x-axis my f of X axis they say okay off
that draw the derivative okay so - okay
now it really really will help you have
you if you have another color or you're
gonna have to dot lines that kind of
pencil but you'll also need a ruler
there okay so going from F to F - just
different cheating ones one of the most
important features okay we're going to
mainly look for stationary points right
because anyway there's a stationary
point here what does that tell you that
the first derivative should be zero
raccoon so I would get i'll get my ruler
okay and sometimes they'll actually give
you an extra sheet of paper on the end
of the exam and you'll have this honor
another thing they'll say attach
including your answers right but they're
quite fire-pot so that's always fun yeah
alright so with my other color let's see
how this works your line of T stationary
points
okay and you draw down so now you know
your festivity it's going to land there
okay and you repeat the process for the
other stationary point as you can see
this is actually on the axis so I don't
need to draw another line there there we
go all right yeah don't get confused at
this point
now that I know I've got these two
points where it's zero okay I need to
know what it does in between those
places yeah so derivative the gradient
function tells you that is this
increasing or decreasing right so on the
graph of F I'm going to label where
there I'm increasing or decreasing so
let's look at the left of this station
point am i increasing or decreasing
increasing and I'm sometimes you'll see
it signified with plus sign papers okay
so I'm increasing and then at the
stationary point I'm not I'm not
increasing more okay so that's one zero
so that means that if you kind of see
I'm out of colors that usually is green
for this but since my gradient xu+ here
when I come down to this graph I ought
to be above the answer's no to be drawn
somewhere here that's light enough what
we do okay
all right in the same way what am i
doing between the stationary points
decreasing
and you can see usually if it's if it's
a turning point it's gonna flip the
other way
okay so I'm going for its positive to
negative back up to positive again and
now I just have to sketch something it's
going to go through those regions and
satisfy that now I should be careful as
well there's one more feature that I've
missed off the graph of f that I hadn't
taken notice of yes that's right so C's
is a point of inflection in here what's
that gonna mean for F - that should be a
stationary point down here it should be
careful with your language because you
like stationary point yeah it doesn't
mean station for ya right so just watch
out into the mode so this again we have
a rule around typically what you get I
mean what I've drawn is a cubic right so
you're generally lucky with those the
point of inflection will be symmetrical
there's to be symmetry between the two
points so throw that down it ought to be
halfway okay so I'm gonna get my station
wait for a festive evening okay and
that's it now we just draw a little face
whereas they get trickier is if you
never get asymptotes involved that kind
of B which you've got a vertical or
horizontal asymptote sorry a horizontal
or oblique asymptote up here let's just
suppose there's a pose it did this it's
at another station and suppose it
approached y equals zero okay so
everything else is not changed okay what
am I going to add to this graph to make
it reflect this okay good so first thing
I had an itch stationary point okay
so you always think about big features
first like like station quotes and then
you add little features in like the
inflection point afterwards okay so like
you said we just added a stationary
point okay so that means that at this
point in here it's going to go okay now
it's positive positive zero and maybe
maybe immediately given me but it's not
just any negative is it okay so yeah
there's a point of inflection somewhere
around here my car today roughly let's
see that still looks concave down to me
right and then somewhere around here it
changes to concave up
yeah so it's quite subtle so someone on
an unemployment so that means that on
this graph I'm
have a stationary point okay
now one last thing as this approaches
infinity as X approaches infinity what
is the green innovation
- sewer I suppose from the - Sun right
okay so it is it is gonna be a negative
number because I'm decreasing all the
way right but I shouldn't be getting
closer to the answers so did you catch
that my gradients approaching zero yes
sure what's gonna happen here all right
I've missed the point inflection have a
nine yeah because you're thinking house
is gonna come back down so so what's
gonna happen instead of that kind of
shape it's gonna come up but then it's
going to slow down here we go so that's
the UM that's the point at which its
steepest okay so that's why that's the
point that the gradient is okay I'm
going to come all the way back down
there we go there's my stationary point
I'm going to turn around again another
ploy reflection now what happens I've
got our approach zero this is really
wonky sorry
it's got my access
okay so in this case F is approaching
zero and F dash is also approaching zero
can you think of a situation where F
dash will not approach yeah that's right
okay so all the functions you can use
the idea right if you didn't catch that
what why my efficiency right here what
you differentiate it right into here you
can zero okay but if I had let's just
sit him up again shall we
I'm so tired why do you keep doing this
to be so suppose so please is actually
in a really castle that's so let's
ignore that one there okay
so sub League asymptote there now
therefore as X approaches infinity
what's happening to the gradient it's
not approaching zero where is its
ingredients it's it's gonna be
approaching some sort of positive
constant isn't its increasing but it's
not it's not climbing and getting
steeper is thicker asleep are it's
actually getting less steep investing
opportunity for that you know 45 degrees
in which case what's gonna happen here
I'll have a horizontal asymptote yeah at
that constant right so let's see here
there's my other stationary point and I
keep adding stationary points so I'm
gonna have to come back up to zero
yes so I go through the axis and now I'm
pretty much constant okay my constant
gradient that is and I think we'd better
leave the graph based you enough I think
it's more like an ADC sign actually ABC
doesn't make that sound anymore do they
I'm strong I'm showing my age I don't
know what sound ABC making you do you
know why that comes